[Musique]
chez les shadoks la situation est
satisfaisante
les essais de fusées continue à très
bien rater car c'était un des principes
de base de la logique shadok ce n'est
qu'en essayant continuellement que l'on
finit par réussir ou en d'autres termes
plus ça rate plus on a de chances que ça
marche
et comme il voyait justement que les jb
ne faisait aucun essai de fusée
il était persuadé que ce serait te les
shadoks qui seraient les premiers sur la
terre et qu'elle leur appartiendrait il
commençait donc à essayer très tôt le
matin les essais ratés d'abord pendant
toute la matinée
quand tout allait bien on arrivait à en
rater six quelquefois set mais c'était
rare vers midi il prenait un repas léger
ça continuait ensuite jusqu'à la nuit et
le lendemain de très bonne heure il
recommençait les jbe à l'autre bout du
cosmos continuer tranquillement à
surveiller leur jardin et à récolter des
graines de moteurs électriques et de
beaucoup d'autres choses pour les
emmener sur la tête et le soir comme
d'habitude en rentrant deschamps il
regarder où les shadoks en était mais
maintenant c'était beaucoup plus amusant
car depuis que le marin shadoks était
partira bateau dans l'espace
il avait deux programmes et ici il en
avait assez de voir les shadoks raté
leur essai il regardait les marara mais
quand il avait vu que ces innocentes des
et espérer arriver chez eux pour leur
voler nos fusées ils avaient d'abord cru
mourir de rire
puis il avait décidé de lui se faire car
10 utile ça valait la peine de regarder
de plus près des animaux aussi rigolo
[Musique]